moi fabien j'ai une question c'est quoi
la réponse à tous et la réponse aux
questions de l'univers aux questions de
la vie ok tu vois la grande réponse
seule celle qu'on attend qui englobe
tout ouïe 42 42 quoi d'être accorde moi
j'ai le nombre mais j'ai pas l'unité en
fait donc le juste c'est 42 peut-être à
7,42 salut 40 de ce nombre vous dit
peut-être pas grand chose et pourtant il
s'agit d'un nombre qui a modifié le
point de vue la pensée le buy-in 7,2 du
monde et de nombreuses personnes en tout
cas 42 ce serait la réponse à la grande
question sur la vie l'univers et le
reste 42 ce serait la réponse à tout
même le site de la sncf il vous répond
42 quand vous lui posez la question je
vous jure
coïncidence je n'y crois pas l'histoire
vient en fait d'une plaisanterie dans un
livre de science fiction que j'ai avec
moi le livre de douglas adams le guide
du voyageur galactique mais il s'avère
que ce chiffre est bien trop présent
dans le monde pour avoir été choisi
vraiment au hasard alors loïc générique
[Musique]
alors d'où ça vient à l'origine de 42 il
ya un feuilleton radiophonique a ensuite
été adaptée en roman h2g2 le guide du
voyageur galactique
il s'agit du premier volume d'une
trilogie en cinq tomes déjà là c'est pas
normal trilogie qui sera par la suite
décliné en pièce de théâtre en comédie
musicale en séries télé en jeu vidéo en
films et même en comics les romands ont
été écrits entre 1979 et 92 par
l'écrivain scénariste britannique
douglas adams qui est décédé en 2000 un
jeune à l'âge de 49 ans douglas avait
notamment participé à l'écriture de
certains sketch des monty python quand
même si vous connaissez pas c'est juste
la réf en humour absurde
h2g2 le guide du voyageur galactique
c'est un roman de science fiction
humoristique
alors ça raconte quoi ce lip ce livre ça
raconte l'histoire d'arthur d'inde qui
tente au tout début du roman d'empêcher
des conducteur de bulldozer de détruire
sa maison pour laisser place à une
nouvelle déviation hyper bazille la même
journée arthur découvre que son ami
forte prefect est en fait un
extraterrestre qui lui annonce que la
terre va être exposé dans 10 minutes
pour laisser place à une nouvelle
déviation mais ce coup-ci
intergalactique la terre se fait
exploser et les deux amis montent in
extremis à bord d'un vaisseau spatial le
coeur en or ça c'est la base de ce livre
est le meilleur compagnon de route
d'arthur dans cette aventure se trouvera
être un livre électronique qui contient
tout le savoir de tous les mondes qui
peuplent dans la galaxie
le guide du voyageur galactique ça vient
de là le barça d'accord mais du coup 42
ça vient d'où tendant dans l'histoire eh
bien ça arrive à un moment où le super
ordinateur qui s'appelle pensée profonde
répond à la question sur la vie
l'univers et le reste après 7,5 millions
d'années de calcul
donc en gros on lui pose la question il
calcule durant 7 5 millions d'années et
enfin il donne la réponse à la vie
l'univers et c est dit la réponse
les calculs sont précis c'est 40 donc
les lecteurs comme le protagoniste se
pose un peu la même question que nous
pourquoi 42 et face à l'engouement de
ses lecteurs douglas adams se voit
obligé de réagir à la réponse donnée par
sa machine et dira c'était une
plaisanterie il fallait que ce soit un
nombre un petit nombre ordinaire est
plutôt donc petit et j'ai choisi
celui-là
j'étais assis à mon bureau j'ai regardé
dans le jardin et j'ai pensé 42 sayeras
et je l'écris fin de l'histoire
douglas aurait également expliqué que
john cleese qui a célèbre membre des
monty python avaient utilisé ce nombre
comme chute à l'un de ses sketchs parce
que juste il trouvé ça marrant
alors pourquoi tant de ramdam pour un
nombre qui a l'air si quelconque
et bien parce que il est peut-être pas
si quelconque que ça on voit ça tout de
suite à la sortie du livre de douglas la
culture geek s'est accaparé le nombre 42
qui est devenu vraiment une joke
d'informaticiens dans les années 80 tu
disais 42 silhouette y comprenez tu
savais qu'ils savaient mais la blague
est allé bien plus loin que ça et 6,42
n'avait pas été choisi au hasard
pourquoi bien parce qu'on le retrouvait
déjà dans beaucoup de
bien avant que douglas adams il fasse
référence dans le guide du voyageur
galactique en sport 42 c'est par exemple
la distance précise à parcourir 100 km
pour un marathon pourquoi 42 parce que
c'est le messager de filippi des skis en
490 avant notre ère a parcouru la
distance marathon athènes soit 42 km
pour annoncer la victoire contre les
perses coïncidence je n'y crois pas
42 se démarque aussi en astronomie
puisqu'il ya 42 s'éclipse de lune et 42
éclipse de soleil dans un sarrau as a
rossé une période de 223 mois de lune et
zon grâce à laquelle on peut prédire les
éclipses de soleil et de lune en
physique l'angle soleil goutte d'eau qui
tombent oeil doit être de 42 degrés pour
que vous puissiez voir un arc-en-ciel
coïncidence je ne crois pas encore plus
étonnant dans la torah et dans la bible
il ya 42 lignes de texte par colonne en
littérature 42 ça revient régulièrement
dans les textes de lewis carroll alice
au pays des merveilles
on le retrouve aussi dans roméo juliette
de shakespeare et c'est en maths que 42
vraiment pas banale du tout 42 c'est la
somme de trois premières puissances de
deux d'exposants un pr42 c'est la somme
des deux premières puissances de 6
d'exposants n'ont nulle 42 c'est un
nombre catalan un nombre pratique un
nombre h
arshad whaou il est aussi le seul nombre
avec 24 dont le carré des chiffres qui
le composent est identique 1 4 ^ égal de
puissance 4
bref vous l'avez compris on trouve le
nombre 42 partout mais là je vous vois
venir vous dites oui mais alors à ce
compte-là on trouve n'importe quel
nombre dans plein d'endroits aussi mais
c'est vrai vous avez raison plein
d'autres nombre appartiennent également
à desserrer quand même la loire c'est le
42e département français alors si si
c'est vrai c'est pas un
il ya quand même un endroit où le nombre
42 à poser plus de problèmes que
n'importe quel autre nombre inférieur à
100 c'est le problème des trois cubes
est-ce qu'on peut écrire 42 sous la
forme a occupe plus b occupe lui c'est
au cube et bien croyez où le oui non
mais 42 était le dernier pour lequel la
solution était trouvée pas plus tard
qu'en 2019 à rendre au bout coeur et
andrew sutherland
ils ont utilisé le système de calcul
charité engine pour réaliser cet énorme
calculs complexes
ray complexe tellement complexe qu'il a
demandé un travail qui aurait été
réalisé en 1 million d'heures soit plus
d'un siècle s'il avait été effectué par
un ordinateur de bureau classique 42
existait donc bien avant de glace adams
mais ce qui est très très fort c'est que
la culture geek n'est pas resté enfermé
et que le 42 s'est fait une petite place
discrète dans notre quotidien sans que
vous en ayez conscience aujourd'hui plus
que jamais la culture geek est rentré
dans la culture populaire
pas besoin d'être un adolescent devant
son clavier devant son écran pour être
un geek et la culture populaire
c'est justement là on retrouve
maintenant le plus le nombre 42 même à
des endroits peut vraiment vous auriez
pas soupçonner voici les six mois qui
m'ont le plus marqué par exemple le
système de radiotélescopes atta c'est le
aliens télescope array est placé au nord
de la californie il est composé de
quarante deux paraboles et ce serait
vraiment en l'honneur de douglas adams
ensuite si vous allez sur le site de la
sncf voulait dit mais c'est vrai si vous
allez dans l'onglet aide
vous écrivez dans la barre de recherche
quelle est la réponse à la grande
question sur la vie l'univers et le
reste
devinez qu'est ce qu'on va vous répondre
64 je déconne 1 ces 40 toujours l'acteur
hugh laurie qui faisait partie d'un duo
célèbre dans les années 80 bon l'autre
moitié de son duo s'appelait stephen fry
n'est autre qu'un ami de douglas adams
et devinez quel sera le nombre fétiche
du docteur house quelques années plus
tard interprété par hugh laurie
évidemment 42 merci on retrouve aussi 42
dans la série lost dans la série x files
ou encore dans doctor who mais pour pro
doctor who ya pas beaucoup de surprises
puisque douglas adams lui même a
travaillé sur la série
un quatrième en droit on retrouve 42
aujourd'hui que vous connaissez
peut-être ce sont les fameuses écoles
qui ont été créés par xavier niel les
écoles 42 ce sont les lieux en fait la
formation au codage et entièrement
gratuite et dont la pédagogie basée sur
le peer-to-peer learning autrement dit
c'est un fonctionnement participatif n'y
a pas de cours il n'y a pas de
professeurs on échange le savoir et
enfin les saisons 12 et 16 de koh lanta
ont duré 42 jours bon on n'est sûr de
rien on aime bien se dire que denis
brogniart fait des références au guide
du voyageur galactique
vous pouvez aussi trouver 42 au cinéma
dans iron man ya une grève dans toy
story dans le monde de nemo dans mission
impossible dans matrix donc bien bien
d'autres et évidemment c'est rarement un
hasard dans ces cas là l'une des
premières références ciné pour être bien
être le film français les sous-doués
passent le bac quand même sorti en 1980
ah oui aussi est ce que vous savez
pourquoi les geeks du monde entier ont
célébré le 10 octobre
en 2010 la journée du 42 parce que dans
le système binaire 42 ça s'écrit 1 0 1 0
1 0 le jour du 42e c'était donc
logiquement le 10 10 10 j'aurai encore
si on voulait des dizaines et des
dizaines d'exemples à vous donner pour
vous montrer à quel point le nombre 42
et populaire aujourd'hui mais non je ne
ferai pas une vidéo de 42 minutes c'est
tentant c'était un temps mais non même
si blague à part je trouve que quand on
parle de ça et des occurrences ça passe
très vite stephen fry qui a donc un ami
de douglas adams dit savoir pourquoi 42
pourquoi douglas hurley pris 42 il a
déclaré que ce choix est fascinant
extraordinaire et que quand vous y
réfléchissez vraiment bien et bc
complètement évident alors douglas at-il
réellement pris 42 au hasard finalement
est ce que ce serait pas une série de
coïncidences qui nous fait penser que 42
est un nombre particulier et si en fait
tout cela avait un sens caché qui nous
mènerait vraiment grands mystères de la
vie de l'univers et le reste ça ce
serait dingue le mystère rien et un peu
entier mais dites-moi en commentaire ce
que vous vous en pensez
moi ce que j'en pense c'est que quand on
veut choisir un peu un nombreux hasard
et un nombre quelconque c'est pas si
simple
c'est un peu comme quand on veut
dessiner une forme quelconque s'est
jamais vraiment quelconque en fait parce
que en voulant aller vers quelque chose
qui ressemble un peu à rien on a un peu
les mêmes critères on se dit je vais pas
prendre trop au pas prendre trop bas
donc tu te prends vers 50 petit 50 ça se
voit trop donc pour moi c'est pas
étonnant qu'on aille vers 40 ouvert 60
qu'on s'éloigne un peu de l'extrême
et puis une fois que tu es dans la
quarantaine tu dis bon ben vous pas 40
tout pile donc peut-être 40 je sais pas
dites moi ce que vous en pensez
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo moi je m'appelle toujours fabien
olicard n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à
cette chaîne et d'activer la cloche pour
ne pas rater la prochaine vidéo
je vais vous mettre le lien dans la
description vers le guide du voyageur
galactique si ça vous intéresse vous
trouveront un autre refrain de libre
c'est mon dernier livre l'entv de la
manipulation aussi qu'est sorti ya pas
très longtemps
en gros comment reprendre le pouvoir
sans prendre celui des autres bon résumé
like est partagée comme d'habitude
vraiment pensé à vous abonner à checker
si vous êtes abonné ou pas à ces chaînes
comme à ma chaîne secondaire d'ailleurs
les vidéos sauf le dimanche
une fois tous les quinze jours sur la
chaîne secondaire et puis là je vous
mets deux autres vidéos celle ci cette
vidéo sur la sérendipité c'était
découverte qu'ont été fait par hasard
et vraiment c'est très très cool et
celle ci c'est une vidéo sur les
caresses le contact son impact
un petit peu sur notre cerveau en gros
avec la pandémie on en n'a pas pu se
toucher est ce qu'on pourra se retourner
vaste question à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]